in the main video on crypto currencies I
made two references to situations where
in order to break a given piece of
security you would have to guess a
specific string of 256 bits one of these
was in the context of digital signatures
and the other in the context of a
cryptographic hash function for example
if you want to find a message whose
sha-256 hash is some specific string of
256 bits you have no better method than
to just guess and check random messages
and this would require on average two to
the 256 guesses
now this is a number so far removed from
anything that we ever deal with that it
can be hard to appreciate its size but
let's give it a try two to the 256 is
the same as two to the 32 multiplied by
itself eight times now what's nice about
that split is that two to the 32 is 4
billion which is at least a number we
can think about right it's the kind of
thing you might see in a headline so
what we need to do is appreciate what
multiplying four billion times itself
eight successive times really feels like
as many of you know the GPU on your
computer can let you run a whole bunch
of computations in parallel incredibly
quickly so if you were to specially
program a GPU to run a cryptographic
hash function over and over a really
good one might be able to do a little
less than a billion hashes per second
and let's say that you just take a bunch
of those and cram your computer full of
extra GPUs so that your computer can run
4 billion hashes per second so the first
4 billion here is going to represent the
number of hashes per second per computer
now picture 4 billion of these GPU
packed computers for comparison even
though Google does not at all make their
number of servers public estimates have
it somewhere in the single-digit
millions in reality most of those
servers are going to be much less
powerful than our imagined GPU packed
machine but let's say that Google
replaced all of its millions of servers
with a machine like this then four
billion machines would mean about a
thousand copies of this souped-up Google
let's call that one kill ago were thav
computing power
there's about 7.3 billion people on
earth
so next imagine giving a little over
half of every individual on earth their
own personal killer Google now imagine
four billion copies of this earth for
comparison the Milky Way has somewhere
between 100 and 400 billion stars we
don't really know but the estimates tend
to be in that range so this would be
akin to a full 1% of every star in the
galaxy having a copy of earth where half
the people on that earth have their own
personal killer Google next try to
imagine four billion copies of the Milky
Way and we're going to call this your
Giga galactic supercomputer running
about two to the 160 guesses every
second now four billion seconds that's
about a hundred and twenty six point
eight years four billion of those well
that's five hundred and seven billion
years which is about 37 times the age of
the universe so even if you were to have
your GPU packed Killah Google per person
multiplanetary Giga galactic computer
guessing numbers for 37 times the age of
the universe it would still only have a
one in four billion chance of finding
the correct guess by the way the state
of Bitcoin hashing these days is that
all of the miners put together guess in
check at a rate of about five billion
billion hashes per second that
corresponds to one third of what I just
described as a killer Google this is not
because there are actually billions of
GPU PAC machines out there but because
miners actually use something that's
about a thousand times better than a GPU
application-specific integrated circuits
these are pieces of hardware
specifically designed for Bitcoin mining
for running a bunch of sha-256 hashes
and nothing else turns out there's a lot
of efficiency gains to be had when you
throw out the need for general
computation and design your integrated
circuits for one and only one task
also on the topic of large powers of two
that I personally find it hard to get my
mind around this channel recently
surpassed two to the 18th subscribers
and to engage a little more with some
sub portion of those two to the eighteen
people I'm gonna do a Q&A session I've
left a link in the description to a
reddit thread where you can post
questions and upload the ones that you
want to hear answers to and probably in
the next video or on Twitter or
something like that
I'll announce the format in which I'd
like to give answers see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]